well done if your brain was able to
bring back your knowledge
from friday about how to work out the
square roots
plural of a complex number um let's have
a quick look at them and we're going to
use that as our
transition as you might be able to tell
today into the concepts we're actually
going to not just do this lesson
but actually for the next week and a
half which i hope you'll be excited
about
first we're working out the roots of
minus 2i and you can see our pair of
roots here
this one is -1 plus i and this one is
1 minus i um and when you have a look at
both of these together right hopefully
you had a look at this in the exercise
already
but did you notice you're like you're
getting this plus minus thing right this
seems familiar this is like when we're
working out
uh you know in a quadratic equation when
you're finding the roots and you get
this plus minus thing happening
just from the quadratic formula does
that seem familiar so
you've got these kind of you know when
you have a look at the arguments
there's a 180 degree or a pi radians
difference
between them right the other thing that
i think is helpful and
i asked some of you to do this but not
all of you so maybe if you haven't done
this already go and have a look at your
say your first diagram right now
if you've got space go ahead and put the
actual number the number we've found the
square roots of put it onto your argan
diagram i reckon i can squeeze it sort
of this one is down here
on this scheme that's minus 2i when i
think of
my my two square roots i think about
them
i've got two ways to think about them
number one you can think of it as
there's a clockwise square root and an
anti-clockwise square root
or you can think of it as a there's a
short one and a long one
right there's one that gets there
quicker and one that gets a longer um
you can see which is which right when i
describe it that way
to get to -2i in the most you know the
laziest way
um you know it's going clockwise right
so therefore
you could go negative pi on 4 radians
and then
another negative pi 4 radians and of
course you also have the scaling right
what's the modulus
of our original complex number
it's it's two distance from the origin
and so as a consequence the modulus of
your square roots is going to be
the square root of two because you need
to scale and then scale again
um to get to your result right so the
fast way for this particular number is
clockwise
and then there's the long way right um
if you go from
the positive real axis and go around
that way what's the argument of
in this way and this scheme z1 what's
its principal argument
three yeah three over four pi three pi
and four so you can see if i went
anti-clockwise and went another three pi
on four
of course well actually i should be down
here but of course you still get to the
negative imaginary axis so this is a
long way around is clockwise you can see
the same thing for here
minus 3 plus 4i will be somewhere up
here
right so there's a this particular one
the fastest way is going anti-clockwise
in that direction right or you could go
anti-clockwise like so okay sorry that
was
anti-clockwise the first time clockwise
a second time all right
okay now rule off where that is um done
in case you
uh haven't already and if you want to
start drawing this that'd be great
as i said we're going to move from this
idea of square roots
into quite a few different
interconnected
concepts now for those of you who are
following along at home
for me the most natural next step is
we've looked at square roots but they
are not the only kinds of roots that
numbers can have
for example um you could say that the um
i'll try to think of a good one actually
um squaring a cube i should have a
trained professional would have thought
of them beforehand
um you could say the square root of 81
is 9 right you can say the square root
of that is 9. but you can also say
that for nice numbers the fourth root
of 81 the number you multiply by itself
four times
is three right three times three times
three times three will give you
81 do you agree so there's square roots
that was a fourth root example
um cube roots and no no no so generally
speaking
we call these guys nth roots because it
can be to any
degree or any power that you like so
it's a natural transition to go from
square roots which are like the special
one that we deal a lot with
to this general case okay but it turns
out as you can see from the diagram in
order to get there there's some other
knowledge
that we need another sort of building
block like you'll try and solve an
equation that gets out of this and you
won't be able to do it right
and that's because we need to go a
little bit back in time
and talking about talk about solving all
kinds of equations
that end up with complex solutions now
we actually could have done this
much earlier on but i wanted there to be
a justification i wanted to be you know
we're not just solving equations because
we can we're going to solve them because
it's a bridge skill to get to something
else i want to do right
but there's two of them so from square
roots right if we
combine that with solving equations
which have
real coefficients but that end up with
complex
solutions it'll be those two skills
together that you'll find
next week allow us to solve nth roots
but now that we know about square roots
there's actually another kind of
equation and we're going to deal with
both of these today
that you can also solve and that is not
when you have
real coefficients that lead to complex
solutions but
we can actually make the coefficients of
our
x's and our z's we can make those
complex
as well now this is like very notation
heavy so it probably makes more sense if
i give you
an example we're going to do both of
these together
this is an example of an equation let me
make it a bit bigger for you
all the coefficients are real can you
see that 5 and negative 2
and 1. just real numbers okay but when
we go ahead and solve this we're going
to find
that the solutions are complex okay and
maybe if you're having a look at this
thinking about what the discriminant
will be you'll see why okay
what does an equation look like when it
has complex coefficients well the whole
idea is instead of numbers like 5 and
negative 2 and 1
we put in things with imaginary units
and real units together
this is going to look a bit messier
because complex numbers are a bit
messier they have these you know
different components to them but you can
see again well
our a here will be 1 our b will be
negative
outside of 2 plus 6i and then our c our
third coefficient there our constant
will be minus 5 plus 2y
so you can see here you've got complex
coefficients you're going to get complex
solutions
i should point out there is a very very
small family of equations that
have complex coefficients but amazingly
all of the answers all the solutions are
actually real they're very strange and
unusual and not really the focus of the
course
so we're going to do these two examples
shortly together but before we leave off
this i do want to anticipate
next week we're going to focus on nth
roots and we're going to do it in two
kind of halves right the first is we're
going to look at the nth roots of a
special
complex number called unity we love
giving fancy names to things right
um you'll be less impressed by what
unity is once we actually get there but
it is a special number nonetheless
and then once we go from there we're
going to have a look at well what if we
want the square root of
sorry the nth roots of any complex
number so
like i said we're kind of going from
square roots to general nth roots
and then we go from nth roots of this
special complex number to
any complex number so that's going to be
our map for the next little bit
all right now as promised sorry i didn't
realize how light that would look
on your screen so i'm going to make this
an easier to read color
is that any better it's a little bit
better right
let's have a look at these two